true is going to school now so how has
that adjustment been it's weird because
they're in the house all the time and
then they're gone school is really
strange I mean I thought okay you go to
school and it's like half a day yeah no
at this school they go a full day
they're like real adults I'm so sad it's
probably harder on me than it is on her
but she knows how to work me so like the
first two weeks were really hard it was
tears for both of us every day like I
just felt like a monster I'm leaving her
there and she's crying like I didn't
know what to do so I would always be
sitting right outside the door and
waiting and the teacher's like you need
to leave you're making this worse and
I'm like I'm one of those moms now but I
know school's great I just think it's so
weird I'm used to having her with me all
the time and also the whole like I
thought oh you get like a break in the
day when your kid's at school yeah no
you're going to school you make the
lunches do the snacks you go to carpool
I'm lingering at the school for like two
hours because I'm like making sure she's
good by the time I get home foreign
you have like what a couple hours like
one or two hours then you have to go all
the way back and do the whole thing
again I'm like this is forever I think
maybe you're like a better mom or
something because my daughter was like
Deuces like I was like listening I was
like my daughter was like peace I'm
gonna be good like she didn't even so
much easier I mean yes but like I kind
of was like I guess okay maybe this is
our way of our love language no I think
that means you raised a really
independent girl I she's very
independent and that's great I think
I've bathing true for like I did this I
created this monster but I I'm sick and
I sort of love it you know what though I
think what's different though is parents
you're generous too like of with your
duration of kid is like y'all were in
covet too for a couple years with their
kids so again everybody was locked down
right so that's a different thing she in
those like developmental years she's
like with you constantly I think that
was different too and I love it I'm sick
I'm like yes you need me and you don't
want to leave me oh my God like if she
would have been like Deuces I would have
sobbed and gone to a therapist
immediately and
I did not I was I was like you know what
you should get into dance you should get
into chess I was like all the after
school programs how long do you want to
be here for yeah I'm like well and also
there's so many cool I don't know like
what kind of school you grew up in but
the school I grew up and didn't have as
many opportunities as they have now and
I'm just like girl you got all these
things you could be doing at this school
that's so awesome and I get so excited
that she can they do have like they do
baking and different instrument stuff so
like it's so exciting what they have I
didn't have all that ice I know but it
is it's cool to volunteer too just to
see your kids like with other little
humans I know existing and you're like
all right I'm doing all right I know or
like oh God we should all go to therapy
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]